if you'd raise your right hand
do you affirm that the testimony you're
about to give before the committee will
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you god
they're the usa's world-beating gymnasts
now telling their story to a room full
of senators it's not one of glory but of
devastation the olympic team doctor who
sexually abused them as children and the
adults they say allowed it to happen
our first witness simone biles
one of the greatest gymnasts of all time
to be clear
sorry
take your time
to be clear i blame larry nassar and i
also blame
an entire system
that enabled and
perpetrated his abuse
this hearing is investigating the
mishandling by the fbi of one of the
biggest sex abuse cases in the country's
history larry nassar a report found was
allowed to continue molesting because
allegations against him weren't properly
investigated michaela maroney sounded
the alarm but says the fbi minimized her
abuse
i was naked
completely alone with him on top of me
molesting me for hours
i told them i thought i was going to die
that night this was very clear cookie
cutter pedophilia and abuse and this is
important because i told the fbi all of
this and they chose to falsify my report
and to not only minimize my abuse but
silence me yet again
biles said her inability to compete at
much of this summer's tokyo olympics was
due to the ongoing trauma of the abuse
today named one of the world's most
influential people her power extends far
beyond sport martha kellner sky news
washington